I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense you know coming off a perfect
game I think the beauty is to is to be
critical of that the same way you're
critical of a of a really rough game
you know we throw interceptions and
fumble the ball or you lose because of
mistakes you made you have to approach
both of those the same way and that goes
for the media that you that you choose
to look at or don't look at it cannot be
all the positive on the great weeks and
don't look at anything on the bad weeks
for me it's really unless there's
something that I need to see that you
know Tom Fanning sends me it's you know
you don't look at much I don't I don't
look at any of that when we win we lose
you lived it and that's the mind so yeah
and that's the mind said it has to be
you know you have a place for all that
and the place is I'm critical of the
wins I'm critical of the losses what I
can do better how my attitude was out
there how my leadership was what plays
don't have to be smarter about how my
preparation was the those weeks what
made it better than others I think
you're always self scouting that's a you
know football term but in life you're
always kind of self scouting you kind of
take an inventory on what's been working
lately habitually you know like what
habits have I been doing that work for
me what do I need to change what would I
like to do better you know I think
that's just kind of a lifestyle so when
it's a lifestyle then you know you don't
get to high and low with it so you do
the same thing either way really yeah I
mean I always say I hate losing more
than I love winning and I where they
love winning so you hate the feeling but
you have to find a spot for that feeling
because what do you mean find a spot
like what what does that mean to you it
means deal with it and put it in its
place it can't be sticking with you okay
compartmentalize yeah you know the next
week so when's the first time you
address it after a game because first I
mean people are tortoise you're
impressive after
you get home from a game that doesn't go
well or even when I've talked to you
after a game that doesn't go well you're
like yeah you know whatever all right
I'll be home you know you're able to
compartmentalize seemingly to me really
well or get over it really well
what's definite not that I don't care no
I I know you I know but this ability to
turn that off is what's presence it's
the balance I think you have to have a
balance you know it's fine my cheery
attitude I don't think I'm talking like
that too you know Leflore or my
teammates or get see your hack you know
like we're pretty awesome out how I
blade what we had to do better you know
it's frustrating when you lose it's
great when you win but there's still
things to clean up all that's yeah it
was probably no game that has more self
analyzation than football I would think
as far as sports well they all do now I
mean they are all in they definitely all
do know they don't have as many days to
look at that film though well they get
to they get to repeat pretty quickly
yeah basketball plays two or three a
week and baseball plays you know four or
five a week and hockey plays two or
three weeks you have a chance to kind of
rebound football you have to sit with it
for longer so yeah I've learned over the
course if I really like how do well in
racing it was the same I mean racing was
one weekend to the next and so here's
always saying like you're only as good
as your last race and you have to sit on
that thought and that feeling for for
one from one week to the next and I have
for sure as you know my spirited
attitude I have for sure let a bad
weekend slip into the next to the next
and then all of a sudden you spiral out
of control so I think it's harder to not
have a game to come back to right away
than it is to have to sit with you do a
really good job thank you yeah some
cupcakes yeah I made you cupcakes when
you come home only if you win though
only if you win
[Music]